a few days after the 2016 election mark
zuckerberg said quote personally I think
the idea that fake news on Facebook
influenced the election in any way is a
pretty crazy idea I think it's safe to
say that 18 months later he probably
regrets having made that statement I
think it's probably apparent to all of
us that Facebook indeed did have an
impact on the 2016 election whether
through fake news or other aspects of
the platform but this is a story that is
of course bigger than Facebook and
bigger than the 2016 election questions
of text impact on our society and our
institutions questions about the kind of
future that that tech is ushering in
might be the most pressing questions
that are facing developed societies
right now I came up in an era of
relative peace and tranquility on the
Internet this is a picture from the
London 2012 Olympics opening ceremonies
they were honoring Tim berners-lee who
invented the world wide web of course
and he's in that little house tweeting
what is being displayed on the LED
screens and the audience is a super cool
in 2012 I guess I started my career
working on internet stuff at Harvard at
exactly the same time that Mark
Zuckerberg was there building the
Facebook in his dorm room and at the
time it felt like everybody was possible
does anyone remember the heady days of
2006 and the rise of the social web yeah
it was great
you know gatekeepers were dying the new
this new printing press that was at our
disposal was going to lower all kinds of
barriers to entry to our democracy to
our economy to cultural production and
that was all a good thing it was you
know disruption wasn't just cool it was
about time and the backlash was of
course fast and Swift
and in in fairness we you know it's now
something that a lot of us are starting
to reflect on but there were people in
fairness at the time who were raising
questions about
you know the ethical responsibility of
the tech sector what the impacts of
these tools we're going to have on
society not just for good but for evil
and that we might need to figure out a
new set of rules and norms to govern
this space that abuse was possible and
we need to figure out how to make sure
that we're channeling these new tools
for the public good but our imagines
imaginations didn't stretch far enough
and the conversations about how we built
this future in an ethical way did not
proceed early or seriously enough the
good news is as I said many people who
were kind of in the space at that time
are starting to enter a real period of
reflection and investing real resources
into figuring out answers to these
questions so Pierre Omidyar who through
his OMA D our network he's a co-founder
of eBay his investment vehicle the
Omidyar Network has started what they're
calling the tech and society Solutions
lab and they're investing millions in
dollars millions of dollars in
organizations that are like the like the
tech equity collaborative that are
starting to examine and work on some of
these ethical issues in tech and a
little ecosystem of organizations is
starting to emerge some of whom have
been around for a long time
others have emerged since the 2016
election and that ecosystem is is
starting to organize itself a little bit
this is my very complicated diagram of
what this ecosystem is starting to look
like there's sort of three main buckets
of work and then a couple of through
lines the first is information and
democracy I think that's really what
most people are thinking about right now
and they think about tech and ethics is
the impact of course that technology has
on the quality of information and the
effective of technology especially
social media technology on our public
decision-making process a lot of money
is going into you obviously figuring out
how we combat fake news and and prevent
and sort of create healthy information
ecosystems second realm is sort of I
would say personal health and
relationship space so
there are organizations like the Center
for Humane technology which is started
by Tristan Harris a former Google at the
Design ethicist
and they've started something called the
time well spent project which you know
obviously looks at the the health
effects of screen time and interactions
with with social tools on a personal
health and then the section that I'll
spend the most time talking about and
where we work is on text impacts on the
economy and not just the tools and
platforms and the business models of the
technology companies but the economic
impacts of the companies themselves and
the people who work in them and then of
course these through lines which I'm
sure you guys are more familiar with
diversity and inclusion in tech which is
not just a sort of a moral issue about
how we create more representation in the
tech industry but is also becoming much
more imperative given that I think it's
a pretty compelling argument that to the
extent that we have more diversity and
inclusion in tech companies we create
some resiliency in the industry to some
of the pitfalls that we see and
decisions that are made that could have
end up having harmful effects on on
certain communities and then of course
most relevant to you guys is computer
science education which you know a lot
more about than I do but there are lots
of conversations happening right now
around ethics we were just discussing
before this what an ethics curriculum
needs to look like in computer science
education and how computer science
education institutions can play a role
in shaping the way that you know the
future leaders of the industry think
about these issues
so like I said I'm gonna focus more on
the economy and again this is sort of
both the the economic impacts of the
tools and platforms and business models
of the company so that would be
something like how uber treats its
drivers or the way that sort of gig
economy work happens but also the
physical effects of the companies and
the people who work in the companies on
the community
where they are based which is really
tech equities main focus and I came to
this work a couple of years ago when
uber announced that they were buying an
old Sears department store building in
downtown Oakland which I happened to
live across the street from and moving
about 2500 employees there and the
reaction from the community at the time
was quite negative I don't know if does
anyone remember this story did it yeah
it didn't reach Palo Alto but it was a
it was quite an issue in my neighborhood
and because you know as Michael
mentioned I've been working at the
intersection of Technology and civics
for a long time and so I was obviously
personally interested in what was
happening across the street from my
apartment but also professionally
interested in the way that the community
was reacting to birth announcement
moving into town and I started thinking
about you know you know stepping back
and reflecting on why the community was
reacting this way and what it meant for
the future sustainability of our economy
that the most valuable privately held
company in the world could make such an
announcement that they were moving good
jobs to an economically distressed place
and the community would not see value in
that for them so I started doing a lot
of thinking about how we got here
and I knew the story that they moved
there and some pushback were the
activists able to get any of those
things that they were desiring funny the
funny conclusion of this story it turns
out uber ended up selling the building
and they may or may not end up really
seeing some space in the building but it
won't be 2500 workers as they originally
announced and I you know I don't think
in my opinion I don't think that the
protests had much to do with that this
was a period of time when Hoover was
going through some other transitions and
I think had a lot bigger things to worry
about then you know there this office
that they had purchased in Oakland
they not do that at all yeah they did
not do that at office so it was they
were calling it their East Bay
headquarters and it was really like a
satellite headquarters but they were
also still in the process of building a
new headquarters in in San Francisco
sort of down the bay a little bit so
this was going to be you know part of
the conversation was what teams were
gonna move there but it was going to be
headquarters employees in there sort of
satellite headquarters office you know I
think what ended up happening is that
the new CEO came in and as Travis was
leaving the board was taking a harder
look at at the finances and we're
wondering what the hell does hundred and
fifty million dollar asset was on their
books and why they needed it when they
were building another headquarters in
San Francisco and ended up selling the
building so you know as I was reflecting
on on the community's reaction to this
decision or this announcement I started
thinking about how we had gotten to this
place it seemed to me to be a pretty
scary indicator of the future
sustainability of our economy that you
know the community at large would see
the growing sector and remember this is
pre ubers current you know extremely bad
reputation there were still only just
like middle-of-the-road bad at the time
and and really thinking about how we got
here because as someone who grew up
outside of Detroit in in the 80s you
know it just seemed strange to me that a
company like this could announce the you
know thousands of new high-paying jobs
and the community would not see value in
that we would have probably thrown a
parade in Detroit at the time so you
know we're how did we get here and this
this we are entering the depressing
graphs and charts part of the talk
obviously we all know that inequality
has been growing in developed societies
over the last several decades
that that any growth in inequality is
particularly stark in the Bay Area in
Silicon Valley
this chart is rents in the ninth
Bay Area over the last eight years or so
this is percent change in rent clearly
it is growing much faster than real
wages are and lest anybody tell you that
the answer to this problem is just to
build more housing we really need to
look at the stark difference between how
much how much housing we're building for
people who are making good money and how
much we're charge how much we're
building for people who are in the
middle and working class this this graph
I hope is one thing you take away from
this as any resident citizen of this
region to understand the housing crisis
you really need to understand this graph
we are just critically behind on
building an affordable housing in the
region and of course we are also losing
middle wage jobs so the growth in in the
job sector is really happening at the
bottom and top ends and wages for middle
wage jobs are growing much slower than
for everybody else and what this means
obviously is is that we're losing the
middle class so this top line up here is
is is how you know percentage of the
population in Silicon Valley that's in
the middle class the bottom two are the
upper class and the lower class higher
income lower income and and and what
this results in is displacement so
literally almost on a one-to-one basis
we are replacing middle and low income
residents with high income residents
we've seen an increase in Santa Clara
San Mateo San Francisco counties of
people who make over $200,000 a year or
sorry over $150,000 a year is about
nineteen thousand five hundred and we
have lost nineteen thousand in every
other income category yeah explanation
for why we're seeing an increase of the
low income well I like that I would
wouldn't think that would be true is it
providing services yeah yeah so you know
$15 an hour jobs I drove through Palo
Alto on my way here today there's a lot
of nice-looking Gardens
in this town somebody's doing that work
somebody's working you know in the
service industry
those folks many of them you know I
don't think you see it around here as
much as you do in Oakland in San
Francisco right now but the the
homelessness crisis is totally off the
charts at this moment a lot of those
people all have jobs and they have a
choice between being homeless and
keeping the job that they have that is
you know in that community or moving far
enough out that they can't reasonably
commute to that job so this gap between
the low income and high young income is
is really a problem so you know you
start putting all this together and it
starts to look like a real rational
decision for you know people in my
neighborhood to say I don't think Oberer
moving here is good for me you come into
town is a literal one-to-one replacement
of me and my community
although I'm you know from the outside
that makes it might seem like an
irrational choice and you know in
addition to that those kind of economic
realities and maybe more importantly to
this sort of dynamic that we're seeing
is this perception that the tech
industry just doesn't care about this
issue that you know you get on you see
Google employees and Facebook employees
getting on their buses in the morning in
San Francisco going down to their very
exclusive campuses where everything is
provided to them getting back on their
private buses and going to their you
know $5 coffee shops and not interacting
with anybody else and not engaging in
the set of conversations that are
happening around what to do about this
problem and that drives this really ugly
and toxic civic dynamic which is a
tragedy because as Michael said I've
been organizing tech workers for longer
literally than just about anybody on the
planet it's a very small group of us and
I know that the majority of people who
work in this industry care about their
communities so this was all kind of
going through my mind as I was looking
at the reaction to were moving to town
and why
the community was fighting it instead of
celebrating it and that's where tech
equity was born so if if you know if we
see this you know company like uber
moving to town and people fighting it
and and how we got to that point I
started thinking a lot about what would
need to change in order for my community
to celebrate uber coming to town and and
we're tech equity is really an attempt
to answer that question so we're a
vehicle for people who work in the tech
industry who want to bend the moral arc
of the industry a little bit closer
towards justice we educate tech workers
about economic issues and inequality in
the Bay Area we are connecting them with
volunteer opportunities to use their
skills and resources to support the
organizations who are on the frontlines
of these issues and we bring their
voices to advocacy fights for things
like increased funding for affordable
housing development and reforms to our
very regressive property tax laws at the
moment we are exclusively focused on
these economic issues housing and
workforce and labor being really the key
issues and and really targeting the bay
area but my longer-term theory of change
is that by connecting the rank-and-file
employees in this company getting them
out of their buses and out of their
exclusive campuses and connecting them
to a wider set of perspectives that we
can infect the companies from the bottom
up with a new ethos of empathy and
citizenship and that hopefully informs
the product design and business
development decisions at the companies
and has implications not just for Tech's
impact on our economy but also for the
other two parts of this sort of tech and
ethics landscape that I mentioned
earlier and I'm hopeful about this
because I've seen it happening I've seen
these glimmers of hope this is Aaron
Lewis he is one of our members he's a
product designer at uber and after he
came to one of our events a couple of
months ago he wrote this blog post
reflecting on the the event was a
documentaries for
a film about gentrification in
California and he went back and did some
reflecting and wrote this blog post you
know after he went to work the next day
thinking about what empathy meant in in
the sort of user research and product
design process at a company like uber so
that kind of sentiment is exactly what
we're trying to create at scale across
the industry and it is happening in
larger groups of people at companies -
this just happened very recently
SurveyMonkey just enacted some new rules
around how their how they treat their
contract employees so these are really a
subclass of employees at tech companies
that do all the things the sort of
service related jobs like janitorial
services security services the cafeteria
all of the kind of support staff around
the full-time employees and this has
started started to be an issue that has
come up at a lot of tech companies that
full-time employees are really
uncomfortable with that sort of caste
system internally and they have been
told for a long time that there are
labor law reasons why the contracted
labor employees can't be treated the
same way that they are like for example
they are not allowed to come to the
company holiday party and things like
that somehow survey manager SurveyMonkey
has managed to figure out a way around
that and they are now providing more
benefits to this class of employees and
it's because when they the company's
sent out the benefits survey to the
full-time employees the employee said I
like our benefits what I don't like is
that everybody else all these other
employees that we share the space with
don't get access to those benefits as
well
here's got me there counselor myself all
through made that bus drivers and my
cafeteria workers employees whereas all
these other places they're definitely
contractors or through it different
[Music]
something we're gonna be working on is
taking things like this and helping to
standardize them across the industry and
not just make it industry practice but
hopefully translate into public policy
as well and we're seeing it in other
areas too so recently about just over
three thousand Google employees
petitioned the company to stop working
on the Pentagon's drone program so this
is happening in around different issues
we certainly saw this in the wake of the
election around immigration I will never
forget the day I was walking down the
Embarcadero was a Tuesday afternoon in
late January early February and a band
of Google employees comes around the
corner with protests placards and
chanting and I thought okay we're
entering a different era now if we're
starting to see things like this so at
this point some of you guys may be
thinking why tech it might seem a little
unfair to demand of this industry more
than we demand of say the finance
industry or the extractive industries
and and it's a fair question
so I'll try to I'll take a stab at
answering it I still believe in the
early promise of the Internet I still
think that ideals we had and you know
the early in mid 2000s about what the
social web could do are still true and
that the industry that's growing up on
top of what I think is the most
democratizing communications platform in
human history and and maybe the most the
highest ROI investment in public
infrastructure in American history
should be creating more opportunity for
more people rather than consolidating
wealth and driving inequality some of
you may know John Perry Barlow who
passed away this year
he's what a godfather of the internet he
wrote in 1996 we are creating a world
that all may enter without privilege or
prejudice accorded by race economic
power military force or station of birth
we are creating a world where anyone
anywhere may express his or her beliefs
no matter how singular without fear of
being coerced or silenced or into
silence or conformity we will create a
civilization of the mind in cyberspace
may it be more humane and fair than the
world your governments have made before
so I I try to live by that in the work
that I'm doing I think it's pretty clear
that as a whole we've kind of failed to
live up to this and I hope here at
Stanford which is in many ways the
epicenter of the internet and the
birthplace of the modern tech industry
you guys will take this to heart and
figure out how to incorporate it into
your work as you go out into the tech
world so thanks for your time I'm happy
to chat about any parts of this that you
want to discuss housing policy the heady
days of the internet back in the 2000s
what you guys are thinking about as you
face the real world and look at getting
jobs in the tech sector
it's your central question about like
why there was like not welcome I mean I
think one of the fascinating
developments of Silicon Valley Tech has
been this silo lean of a company it's a
community all into itself right and so
if you compare it to finance I'm not
gonna defend finance in any way but like
if you take a you take finance in New
York and the employees don't always they
order out right they'll use the local
community in some way and spend money
there and in many ways our tech
companies today are built to not spend
money there whether it's decreased
productivity so you stay on site or
whether it's to control costs and I mean
simple things like if you just gave
employees vouchers to spend on lunches
in the community would really I think
helped a lot of use would help the local
economy in I mean take a snapshot as an
example and the people are in Venice
they have an organized group there
that's like no snapshot in Venice they
they're leaving that is they can not be
more excited because the economics of
snapshot being in Venice causing many
businesses
to go under no one was spending money
there are people all inside their
snapchat and on top of it rents about
increased and it just it just really was
evidence of how a tech company come into
a space really detriment at that area
mm-hmm
yeah I mean there is we haven't found
and I'm looking to start working on a
project that can quantify the difference
that happens so there's a lot of people
who work on equitable growth in cities
and advise mayor's on how to attract
business and jobs in a way that will
bring opportunity to everyone so that
sort of well-trodden field and feels
like could be applied in instances like
this but I think there's something
different about the tech economy that no
one really understands no one's been
able to point to this is the way that a
tech company moving to town changes the
economy that's different from you know
with a manufacturer or you know we grew
our tourist industry or whatever and so
that that's still kind of an unanswered
question I think it's clear if we kind
of just look at it that it's it's
happening and I think that you know the
way in which tech companies create jobs
is you know at the very high end and the
very low end is clear so there has to
but that requires a policy solution
right I I think it's easy to put this on
tech companies and expect that you know
Travis kalanick and Mark Zuckerberg and
are the ones who need to solve all of
this for us but it's really on our
elected officials and it's really you
know by you know definition on us to
make them do that bus system between the
deal that the mayor made of Twitter and
the bus companies was so weird in some
ways because a simple solution would
have been to let everybody write their
buses I mean there's gotta be workers
who need to get from San Francisco down
here for jobs whether they're to clean
houses for people or whatever and the
fact that they got a tax break it's a
mystical the weren't able to actually
open those buses to the public single
kind of
just absurd as a policy I guess mm-hmm I
wonder how much of that is colored just
by our perception that we you know we
don't know those people right there
separated from us I think you know
without all without that coloring the
conversation I think the idea that
companies are providing transportation
services for their employees of this big
sector of the economy instead of forcing
them out to get into cars it's not the
worst thing I mean what I would have
rather seen is that these companies
banded together and demanded that we we
have better public transportation for
everybody and that their employees ride
Caltrain so that's really where you know
I see where I would hope that these
conversations start going and that
companies tech companies start seeing
their responsibility to the community
and not just to their shareholders and
their employees and I think I'm really
hopeful about the employees being able
to drive those conversations internally
yeah industry what are the the range of
policy interventions that you're working
on that you see is most feasible
including politically feasible because
it just seems that that is driving the
housing that is driving the displacement
yeah yeah and I'll say I also live in
he's saying so you just this is a crisis
now this isn't a future AI you know
exactly you know labor automation crisis
it's not a future crisis it's very much
a present crisis so what from the Bay
Area like what do you see as politically
feasible you know to reduce your median
income yeah yeah I like to say the
future of work conversation is not about
the future and for many people you know
I think that talking about that way is a
little bit tone-deaf and I also think
that housing is a workforce issue a lot
of people are don't see the direct line
between why you know given our mission
we work on housing issues but it's
because housing underlies everything
else in the economy if you can't afford
to live here you can't afford to take
advantage of the jobs here California
has the highest poverty rate in the
country when you factor in the cost
living so this really is the fundamental
economic issue and if we can't fix it we
can't really address anything else so
the concrete ways that we're addressing
this first of all I mean they're the the
housing solution set is known the
challenge is political so our platform
is that we really need to balance the
need the long-term need to create more
supply with the very urgent need to
protect communities in place and that we
need to do both of those and give equal
weight to them at the same time in
California those two those two goals are
seen as in opposition to each other and
we are trying to build a new political
coalition that can bring together the
folks who who are working with the most
vulnerable communities to help them stay
in place now and the kind of tech worker
constituency writ large so younger
better educated people who are making
higher wages but still spending a lot of
money on housing and have no hope of
buying a house because they probably
have hundreds of thousands of dollars in
student loan debt to come together in
this you know fight for housing justice
really and their shared enemy are NIMBYs
landowners who don't who want to keep
their value of their land high which
means not building a lot of housing and
they don't want poor people in their
neighborhoods effectively I mean if you
listen to the rhetoric it's it's
basically all about about that
unfortunately the political dynamics in
California have the younger set of
including tech workers paid it against
the anti gentrification and anti
displacement people I think
unfortunately because of this sense of
text exclusivity and this sense the tech
is driving the housing crisis they're
seen as the enemy
and we are trying to build a coalition
that brings those two sides together and
we're actually having a fair amount of
success so some of you may have heard
this housing bill that just failed in
the state legislature called SB 827 it
would have legalized denser development
near transit stations if we've ever been
to
you know Rock Ridge and Oakland or other
sort of Tony East Bay cities you'll see
a BART station surrounded by parking
lots and single-family homes which is
not a good use of land so this would
have up zoned all those areas by force
it unfortunately died because of a real
a really bad process around how the bill
was introduced but there is a pathway
for it it started a conversation and I'm
pretty hopeful you heard it here first
that we'll see a successful version of
that bill next year the other thing that
we're working on which is which is
fundamental is as I mentioned before
reforming the state's property tax laws
so I don't know how many of you are old
enough or have been here long enough to
know what prop 13 is it was a ballot
initiative initiative passed in 1978
that pigs you're the property taxes you
pay to the value of your property when
you purchased it so there are people who
bought em a house that's where that was
worth $100,000 and they bought it in the
late 70s and is now worth many millions
of dollars and they are paying taxes on
a hundred thousand dollars worth of
property now on the residential side you
know there was an argument that was made
which is fair enough that the rising
value of property and associated rising
property taxes would be unsustainable
for older people who are on a fixed
income and they Baloo's their homes it
turns out though that that law also
applies to commercial and industrial
property so companies like Disney and
Chevron are paying very little in
property taxes I think something like
five cents a square foot and you know
accompany if you were to buy property
today commercial property be paying
something like 16 dollars a square foot
so there's a real discrepancy and what
these older legacy companies are paying
and we are working as part of a
coalition on a ballot initiative that
would reform prop 13 to remove that
protection for commercial and industrial
properties
would bring about six to ten billion
dollars a year in sustainable revenue to
the state 40% of which would go to
public education the other 60% would go
to local services including an
affordable housing development so those
are the kinds of things that we're
working on and that we're getting tech
workers engaged in and and tech
companies too so that will be on the
ballot in 2020
I have petitions in my bag too if
anyone's a registered voter in
California and one wants to put their
name down given that he calls himself a
hybrid libertarian right he was and this
kind of embedded in this mindset where
the hippies were living where people who
felt really opposed to things like the
Vietnam War or the industrial military
complex were actually leaving and going
and living in the desert in these
communes and I think they viewed
cyberspace as a similar area where as I
was talking about things like organizing
tech workers and policy intervention do
you think that this aspiration of
cyberspace is still a good aspiration
trust that's a good question so I do
think he was thinking you know there was
this techno utopian view that the
internet could be this space apart from
governments right I think he probably I
don't want to speak for him but I met
him a couple times I think he would he
was if not convinced convince a bowl
that you couldn't separate the internet
from the government obviously that
control them that are the actual
governance structures of physical space
but that's not to say that the values
the original founding values of the
internet don't have value for us in you
know in real life and that ideal and I
think you know we see that in movements
like black lives matter in me too and
those are the kinds of
real-life revolutions really that that
could only really happen because of the
internet and because of this sort of
decentralized structure of the internet
now how that that starts to interact
with values like fairness and racism and
yeah the things that we that you know
we're gonna run into in the real world I
think those started coming to the fore
pretty quickly after he wrote this but
you know just like the original
Declaration of Independence was really a
set of ideals that ran into real life
challenges when they ever since they
started to be implemented I think we can
still see the words and the ideals that
we were striving for and try to figure
out how to infuse the way that these you
know these tools get implemented in the
real world with that Sensibility usually
when people come into a seminar like
this one and lay out the problems that
that you did they would then say when
they say our platform they don't mean
our like our political platform I mean
here's the thing that building yeah and
I think it's really fascinating that
what you're doing is essentially you
know grassroots organization campaign
and I'm sort of contrasting that with
what I almost was a cynical learned
helplessness of like computer science
people around like engaging in social
government's etc so it's just sort of
been like well at least I can like you
know hold myself up and not worry about
it and you know I guess what I'm trying
to work toward is how are there specific
techniques that you're trying to use to
mobilize tech workers that are specific
to the people who you're trying to
globalize that let's say like wouldn't
we'd never have applied to bankers but
you know that they're clearly certain
kinds of psychological and social norms
that you have don't come in order to
actually make historically somewhat
apolitical
political yeah it's funny we did a lot
of research on what motivates people who
work in tech to be civically engaged and
we had an original hypothesis that
technical employees would would think
about this problem differently than the
non-technical employees at the companies
and we actually found that there wasn't
a difference so maybe it's just an
academia issue and not a Engineers issue
like once they get out into the real
world there's a this sense that oh
actually we you know we need to be
engaged in this too
so I would say I think I don't see that
that often I don't I don't well some
maybe some but I don't think that's the
prevailing view inside tech companies
and yeah I know and I don't I think it's
a stereotype and I think it's part of
what plays into that sense that tech
doesn't care about everybody else that
everything's just an engineering problem
and there's certainly sort of a like
technocratic way of looking at the world
and like how we might solve these
problems that are that can be
frustrating that that you know politics
is not a linear thing and and the work
of relationship building can't be
quantified it's not a math problem but
[Music]
in like kind of a lack of understanding
about the way that power works I think
that's true of a lot of people who come
from sort of upper middle class
backgrounds so I guess I wouldn't
characterize that as just an engineer's
thing so I mean certainly there are some
people who think that way I don't think
it's the prevailing view inside tech
companies and I think what really is the
challenge is that the people who want to
do something different and view their
industry or their profession as part of
the problem don't know where to start
and they feel a little bit paralyzed
yeah futile ways and strategies you
employ to try to build entropy for you
know people around and with the tech
workers how you come combat like apathy
vision
being motivated to spend their time yeah
so we create a bunch of different ways
that access different kinds of skills
and motivations the first and most
important thing is education so we have
an event series we have a book club and
we are really putting our members in
conversation with people who are closest
to the issues and doing so in a safe
space that really is not available
especially in San Francisco and Oakland
to people who work in tech who really
feel demonized like I don't want I mean
it seems a little a little bit more
intense and I mean it to sound but you
know a little bit pushed into the
shadows they don't want to talk about
where they work they don't want to enter
into a public conversation and say there
are a tech worker and so they just avoid
it altogether but there they want to
know more and so our events have turned
into a space for real sort of learning
and examination and self questioning and
in a kind of a healthy way same with the
book clubs I think that that is has been
really powerful in a way that I didn't
think would we would see to the extent
that it has the second is just a set of
volunteer opportunities that we create
so we have a giving circle so if folks
want to give money that and learn you
know develop sort of an ethos of
philanthropy this is an easy way for
them to do that so one member will pick
a topic and then research organizations
who are working in that topic and then
propose three organizations to the group
and then the group decides where to give
the money so that's a way not just to
build a ethos of philanthropy but also
to learn about the organizations who are
doing work in the space and to better
connect our members to those those
groups we also have a board member
training program so we train our members
what it is to serve on nonprofit boards
and then match them with nonprofits who
are looking for board members we're
building a voter info tool right now so
that's sort of a software development
volunteer project so different kinds of
skill sets different ways that people
want to be engaged
we are a lot of our members are out
collecting signatures for this ballot
initiative
some of them come to you know city
council or state legislature hearings to
speak on behalf of the issue so we have
we have policy committees so there's
just a whole range of ways that people
can plug in there's really no excuse not
to to figure out how to get involved
yeah what level of government
do you see interviewing it could be
local state or national the reason I ask
is because I come from Austin Texas and
there there's a very similar thing
happening not as big of a scale but it
people like the tech industry's growing
people are mad about it and Texas has a
very different state government Austin
is that City is very similar to SF and
then maybe a national government can't
intervene so I'm just curious yeah well
they all every level there is something
to be done I think for the you know for
the current state of the housing crisis
the most effective lever to push on is
the state level and that's just because
really the Bay Area is is a region I
mean it is connected regionally our
economy is regional or housing market is
regional or job market is regional or
transportation system is regional there
is no regional authority and there are a
lot of cities including Palo Alto that
have made it really hard to get anything
done on housing at the local level so
given all the different jurisdictions
within the region that you would have to
be in touch with in order to really make
change at scale on something like
housing and how resistant many of those
places have been to that change is just
hard fight and expensive fight the state
obviously it's a little bit of a heavy
hammer but you get everybody at once and
you passed one law and everybody's got
to live by it a lot of people aren't
happy with that but you know at the
current level of crisis that were at it
just you know there
California to regulate at that level how
do we get like a state like Texas well
every state is a little bit different
um I think Texas's issues are probably a
little bit different than California's
on the federal level there is you know I
mean it's a challenge anything
progressive is a challenge at the
federal level right now so you know Ben
Carson who is the head of the department
that makes federal housing policy
doesn't know anything about housing he's
now making a lot of cuts to housing
assistance as part of the federal tax
cuts affordable housing developers lost
a lot of the funding streams that they
get to build new affordable housing and
as you saw from the graph I showed
earlier that's a real that's a real
issue so state of California which
happens to have a lot of economic power
itself is deciding to do a lot of this
stuff on its own so there will be a bond
measure on the ballot November is about
four billion dollars one-time funding
stream for affordable housing
development doesn't go far enough but
it's a start things like the prop 13
reform that we're talking about I mean
it just is the place right now where we
can get anything done and things needed
to be done yesterday so that's where we
have to work yeah
I'm intrigued by your comment earlier
that the work won't be done by the
company executives but it will have to
be done through the policymaking arm of
some state agency at whatever level but
I think you're I want to go back to
several of the previous comments I think
your undervaluing how important the
cyber libertarian perspective has been
in blocking precisely those initiatives
remember that this declaration of
independence of cyberspace is
independence from the government yeah of
the world John Perry Barlow is a major
Republican fundraiser right he could
never be called progressive
right no that's just not what what does
and with what we saw when we were trying
to organize in previous years is this
you know we can't
government be involved in anything
around 1996 we can't let government be
involved in the internet and you know
the cognitive dissonance attached to
that because the internet wouldn't have
existed without 40 years of government
funding you know that just you know it
was so crazy that you didn't know how to
deal with that but I think so many of
the previous initiatives to try to get
something going that is progressive in
this industry and errs on the well we
don't want government to be involved
with anything with this very strong
cyber libertarian ordering on
solipsistic fetish that has been so
common and there been lots of books
written about my question for you is
whether there that's changing are you
seeing that it's not 30 percent
libertarian anymore because it's grown
so much and now maybe it's closer to the
national average I have some sense that
that may be true but maybe you aren't
running it up against that well we
shouldn't be talking to government
government this passe that's it I don't
get that sense from I mean you're
looking at first of all for this value
set I think maybe it's been co-opted by
you know the new techno utopians who you
wouldn't think are those people but I
think the people who are most the most
credible advocates for Internet freedom
right now or for the power of the
Internet to really empower people and
decentralize power are civil rights
activists I was at an event last night
for the Center for Media justice they
are fighting for net neutrality very
hard they see it as a racial justice
issue black lives matter I mean the
leaders of black lives matter are the
ones who are talking about the power of
social media to move movements and of
course you know there's a long history
of the use of media and the need for an
independent media in the civil rights
movement because you know back in the
60s it was about the corporate you know
broadcast media but I so I think maybe
some of these values have been co-opted
by people who are not libertarian but
fighting for a set of tools that can
help empower
or people maybe so that's why I that's
what speaks to me about this quote in
terms of the how the the people who are
running these companies think and
whether there's a libertarian streak
certainly there are still you know the
kind of old-school libertarians in in
the tech world but most of who works
there now is really like the Obama
generation right and and and I say this
is someone who was inspired by President
Obama to get involved in public service
and worked on his campaign you know
there is a big sense that the same
values that kind of animate the internet
were the ones that brought him to power
and and we used networked organizing
structures that mimic the way the
internet works in order to get him
elected so I think that the people who
work in these companies now really
understand their role as citizens and
understand the power of the public
sector
they may not have enough power
internally yet because they're not in
executive level roles yet but I think
collectively and this is where it's sort
of the labor organizing comes into play
you know when they come together and
have a kind of common identity and can
speak as one voice in the way that these
these Google employees are doing I think
we can see a lot of power in that and
and I think there's a lot of people in
tech who are calling for government
regulation right now they don't want it
to be left up to them to figure this out
it is a little scary because I don't
know if you saw anyone saw the Mark
Zuckerberg hearing but I'm not sure I
trust to the people who are in Congress
to be making these decisions either so
we're gonna have to figure it out but it
really is going to require that people
who work in tech companies are engaging
them in public sector conversations yes
question so your focus on and how really
important because one of the arguments
was that you know the tech sector is
only playing these high wage employees
who are bidding up prices and
kind of forcing other people out it may
be even more of a crisis and that in
that it's a feedback loop like the
housing prices being so expensive have
forced tech companies to only have high
wage employees you know you tell tons of
their people to organ in the 80s and 90s
you know Apple manufacturers and
everyone else in Asia like those factory
jobs those were middle-class jobs that
no longer exist here because and then
maybe also that even in some forms your
knowledge work done we see those
startups like call centers and they'd
say they're not going to be here they're
gonna be in Salt Lake City or Texas or
wherever they find it cheaper and so in
some ways the real estate is that real
estates for forcing out jobs that like
do these jobs so I think this focus is
high one thing that can be done is to
take advantage of the tech industry's
competitive nature so for example if you
look at Seattle they've built light rail
that took twenty five years to agree on
but they finally built it and they're
building tones of high-density around
all those train stations and you know
one could say hey look a lot of tech
jobs are moving there we need to keep up
to do this and and we need to set aside
twenty percent of those apartments for
make it sustainable yeah like I said I
mean a solution set is there it's really
a political issue right now and you know
we are seeing tech come to those
conversations more than they have been
in the past but it's true and there's
also a competitive argument to make as
well so the median annual salary at
Facebook right now is about two hundred
forty thousand dollars a year if you're
a start-up you can't afford to pay those
kind of salaries and I think in San
Francisco something like forty percent
of venture capital dollars are going to
landlords through office space or what
the percentage of salaries that have to
go to rent that's a really compelling
argument from a you know competitive
innovative innovation point of view and
so from that perspective that's also an
argument we can make on the
this property tax reform piece as well
so from that perspective I think that
tech companies that's the argument that
really gets tech companies and tech
leaders engaged in these in these
conversations
[Applause]
you